um we have purchased three ball gowns
and you get to choose which ball gown
bob you get to wear for this before we
do that though before we go into that
right if we want to do that all right i
um
it's been weighing on me
it really has
for a long time
and um i owe you
okay and i bought you some presents no
wait hang on nope you're going to
apologize in the ball gown bring out the
ball gowns
where are they i just want to add this
isn't even top 20 terrible things that
have happened to me in stand up [ __ ] all
right good good good there's way thank
you
like this doesn't even this is
like who's playing wearing what i'm the
only one wearing purple's pretty purple
is pretty
i don't like that because i really and i
hate bling but i feel like bling is
appropriate for
oh
and that's sort of that's tea length
yellow no i think um
i think purple i like the
the purple is very cinderella
yeah i i only knew that you thought it
was a ball gown because listeners of
this podcast would come and comment on
random instagram posts of mine you know
like me like meeting my nephew and they
were like
did you wear a [ __ ] ball gown and i'm
like what is this coming from wasn't
even a ball gown what was this um and
then i and then i was able to put two
and two together
[Music]
[Laughter]
your belly is so cute thank you it's
nice
okay so um
i want to look in your eyes okay
number one i want to say um
i've never had an opener right an emcee
rise the way you have in the comedy
business usually when you do open mics
and stuff
or when you see a host at a club you
never see them again
but over the years
um
i've watched you
from afar grow
become a part of the community comedy
community
and you did something that is next to
impossible i mean it's a very difficult
world to get into and
you persevered not only through my
[ __ ]
but other [ __ ] to get to where
you're at and i want to say um i truly
am
deep down super sorry about it it's not
who i am anymore
um
i think about it and uh and i would like
to
have a friendship with you in the
beginning
maybe i could earn my stripes and then
maybe one day you'll like me
for real you know i mean yeah so that's
the introduction so i bought you some
presents and in korean's culture you
can't refute any of the presidents you
have to take it okay all right so would
you like to begin this process
absolutely of nurturing and also of of
what i just want to say that i um i did
i i rose to spite you you know
you were the villain
i see you again i don't know
i know i promise but doesn't that give
you motivation that that does give you
motivation because i've had so much
slight and people [ __ ] me over in this
business or be complete [ __ ] and it
motivates me yeah well and i'm being
genuinely honest of the things that men
have done to me during my now almost 13
years of doing stand-up truly not top
20. oh thank you first um and they are
all true losers
and not have a nice house definitely
don't have a george you know they've got
yeah they've got no one thank you and
people are like you should cancel them
and it's like they're going to kill
themselves
so you just kind of you just look at the
facebook posts and and know that that's
coming yeah so i do i do appreciate your
apology okay good um and
yeah i'm i'm so i'm so happy that
you have at me at five months pregnant
you have a bigger belly than that
i'm gonna let you have that slime and so
that's that's actually apology enough
okay good here we go okay
stitch fix you guys i don't like
shopping you know i know what i like
right but you know i would i've always
dreamed of somebody to kind of know what
i like and then get it for me yeah and
that's essentially what stitch fix is
right
you you fill out a little like form
right it's very